[Musique]
il y a des agneaux dans ce groupe et des
lots dans ce monde
je sais que vous les deux petits gars
vous êtes aux voyageurs épuisés qu'ils
avaient perdu leur semaine donc à
nettoyer vos péchés le matin à faire le
baptême du feu monsieur vient vite à mon
école de l'est jay deviendra c'est une
information capitale sur ce qu'il a
envie de faire pour le restant de sa vie
et mon dessin
vous avez laissé un jeune à moitié nue
atteint du syndrome de down et sans la
moindre idée de ce qu'il doit faire pour
se débrouiller dans la vie disparaître
dans la nature sous votre nez vous étiez
ainsi proches
exact eh bien imaginez où il peut se
trouver ramené le ici mais en train de
me suivre parce qu'on prend et devenir
neko par des bottes comme des frères
rigoler et se raconter des blagues il ya
une école de l'utah et donne tout ça tu
vois cette longue route qui descend je
t'ai conduire je recherche ce jeune
homme est ce que l'un de vous l'aurez vu
sacrer petite fripouille
on est deux bandits de grand chemin
[Applaudissements]
avec le numéro un tu me ralentit pas
hague le numéro 2 je suis le responsable
c'est quoi la règle numéro un
anniversaire non pas tant des
universités bon c'est ça retient ton
équilibre
vague vous êtes avec un jeune homme
atteint du syndrome de tonnes au milieu
de nulle part
et pendant que vous remplissiez sur
dossier nous on a fait un truc qui
s'appelle vivre
tyler tout même meilleurs souhaits pour
versèrent je suis donné ma parole de
l'amener à l'école de lutte et on
montera pas sur votre à fiat fortune
pour naviguer sur faisant dangereux et
léonore je veux pas retourner à la
maison
à 9 h
[Musique]
il y as combien de kilomètres à faire
comme ça sur la carte photo affronte à
l'échelle exact
[Musique]
il est temps de rentrer au centre
maintenant on pourrait une famille les
amis sont aussi la famille que tu t'es
choisi les lutteurs ont tous un alter
ego
il faut ou non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]